[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to film
independent presents our year-round
screening and q a series i'm brian
sheehan with film dependent thank you so
much for joining us today to talk all
things last night in soho
uh first off i'd like to thank some of
our supporters our lead sponsor the hfpa
and our official partner vision media
today we have a very special guest
moderator an acclaimed independent
filmmaker alison anders
and without further ado i will let
alison take it away from here to talk
all things last night in soho all right
edgar christie i'm so excited to talk
about this movie and um which i love i i
can't help it i can't help but gush i
love it so much and this is so rare for
me to say
[Music]
i could live any place in any time i'd
live here in london
in the 60s
last night
i saw something in my dreams
[Music]
you can't save me
so i was talking with our friends joe
dante and josh
uh olsen about my favorite um horror
movies
and
my favorite brand of horror movie
i was telling them is
a woman being haunted by a ghost
and where she's like am i insane or am i
seeing ghosts
and everybody's like yeah you're insane
and then and then it turns out no she is
not insane
so um now i'm gonna have to ask for them
to let me reshoot it so that i can add
this film to my faves
um
i think that what it is is it's a
specific feeling of honoring a woman's
intuition you know that there is
like a really deep intuition
so how did this story come about of this
young woman being haunted
um
and how did i mean edgar you've always
had really great female leads but this
is your first female protagonist and how
did you two come together to give us two
great female characters
well the um there's so many sort of
inspirations for the movie and um
like i'll go through it quickly in terms
of the sort of the key things like i
guess like uh one thing to talk about
the female protagonist and
is
eloise in a strange way is based on my
mother a little bit because my mother is
somebody that is like very
supernaturally switched on
and
certainly like growing up
like with
my mum who would kind of feel presences
and sometimes see ghosts and talk to my
me and my brother very matter-of-factly
about that
it wasn't something where i was ever
like a skeptic i would actually more um
maybe be slightly envious as a horror
fan that as a young horror fan that
she'd seen a ghost and i hadn't there's
definitely something that i i i grew up
with that but also and i think about
this a lot that even though me and my
brother weren't skeptical about it
and wanted to believe her or did believe
her i also kind of knew enough to maybe
not go to school and say hey my mom saw
the ghost of a hangman in the living
room because you know what other people
would think
so and then my mum is still like my mom
who saw the movie the other day for the
first time
actually kristy you can talk about
something that uh my mum said to us um
but uh
you know i think my mum just
maybe saw it kind of almost like a
documentary and then at lunch afterwards
after she saw the movie she was just
like retelling all of the stories that
we'd heard as kids you know in including
her seeing two separate ghosts in our
family house growing up
so that was one aspect of it and and and
and one of the things in the movie
that's kind of um is sort of key to it
is when rita touching him and thomas and
mackenzie talk about her power at the
start it's called a gift but then
anybody else's kind of like sort of
response to it
um especially
you know it becomes something where it's
kind of considered a mental illness
especially when you get to a scene where
you've been with this protagonist the
entire time you've seen what she's seen
you've experienced what she's
experienced
but then when you get to like a key
scene where she has to go and explain it
to the cops
you know like in a sort of cynical male
police officer obviously it sounds like
the rantings of a mad person
so there was something i think sort of
having
had that experience growing up is i was
aware of like what i believed and also
what other people might think and and
you know maybe that's the sort of source
of shame that i sort of like would
believe my mum but not tell other people
that i believed her
and christy share it share that story oh
it was so good when we were i think it
was quite early on in the writing room
we were talking you know a lot about
ellie's gift and sort of you know what
are the rules of her powers and edgar
was obviously telling me about his mom
and your mom sent us this word document
called spooky goings-on and it was just
uh her collections from the years all
her recollections of what she'd seen and
it was there was like a few movies in
that at least it was great
i love it
i love it yes i and i love this idea of
the
of this being a gift i mean she has many
gifts she has a gift and then she's got
her
her um gift that she can share but even
at that
it's complicated by people not quite
buying it you know sort of the mean
girls there at the at the uh at the
academy
um
so how did the how did you two come
together to start writing this together
well
i'll do the the i'll do the short
version of it because the sort of the
film sort of existed in my head
literally haunting me for maybe a decade
before i even met christy or maybe like
close to a decade but i've just been
thinking about this film for a long time
and there'd been like a few sort of key
things that had really inspired it
one had been
growing up like my obsession so i was
born in 1974 so
i have nostalgia for a decade that i did
not live in and i think there's an a
sense that you have you know people have
nostalgia for the decade they just
missed
and it started with my parents record
collection because they had one box they
only have one box of records which i
never saw them growing up ever play
so i quickly inherited them because it
was like well if they're not listening
to them i'm going to listen to them and
they were 60s albums that seemed to stop
dead when my older brother was born like
no 70s albums it was just like 60s
albums so i would obsess about the music
and in the kind of like
in the sort of uh for the older people
out there who remember the times before
the internet where there was nothing
else to go on other than what you had in
front of you like i would just listen to
the albums and read all the small print
and look at the pictures and form my
opinion of the decade based on that and
then growing and this is from like i'm
talking when i was like six years old
but then like through like
film and tv and music and art and
fashion just this sort of idea that like
the this the decade that i wasn't in was
like the best time ever and like what an
incredible time
and then that would turn into sort of
time travel fantasies about like
frequently
dreaming about going back to the 60s and
you know and sort of having these kind
of cultural trips back in time like if
you were like wouldn't it be great to go
back and be at that gig or go and see
that film with an opening weekend
audience or like be at that show or go
to that club
but um
and the more that that started to kind
of like plague me you start to feel like
is this actually like do i have a
problem
is nostalgia itself
a retreat from modern life am i
retreating from dealing with the
problems of the present day so that was
one big aspect to it
and the idea that then started to kind
of the idea of a theme of like
the danger of romanticizing the past and
the danger of like if if your wish came
true and you could get to go back
like you can't have the good without the
bad and that's essentially and then and
then moreover and this is the kind of
stuff where in dreams that become
nightmares the idea of going back but
not being able to do anything to change
future events
so she's not eloise is not a time
traveler like martin mcfly she can't
change the outcome of the future she can
only essentially watch and that first
could be a thrilling intoxicating thing
and then when things get darker and you
can't do anything to save somebody that
becomes the nightmare
and then i'm coming to christy
[Laughter]
the second part of it i'll get through
this quickly the second part is moving
to london and moving to london and then
living in london for 27 years and
spending
the majority of my time through work and
socializing in soho because if you don't
know soho in london it's the center of
the film and tv industry it was the
center of show business it's like clubs
you know cinemas theaters everything a
big nightlife district but also
um
you know the heart of the underworld and
the sex industry
that part of it has sort of been
like mostly um
uh kind of like um
you know kind of is sort of
has changed but it's still there a
little bit
um so
you know it's mostly been gentrified out
but not quite and as christie can well
christy can talk about her own
experiences but it's just something that
soho after midnight it's almost like
brigadoon the sort of the the kind of
the the
the darker half comes back and it's kind
of really sort of a weird and disturbing
and compelling energy change in the area
so there was a big part of that like
being obsessed with the 60s being back
in soho and just thinking about the
ghosts
of the past and being in buildings that
are hundreds of years old and thinking
about what these walls have seen
that was really praying on my mind so i
started to formulate the story
and then about a decade ago i mentioned
it to my producers naira park and rachel
pryor
they love the idea but because it has a
lot of darker themes than anything else
i've done before the first thing i
wanted to do was research it and because
i was going off to do another movie we
had this amazing researcher lucy party
to
just won a bafta for the casting
directing on rocks
she basically whilst i was doing another
movie the world's end she started
researching it and
i had this like tone
of like almost all my worst fears
confirmed everything that i
thought or kind of had heard second or
third hand or even
worse back in those days in terms of the
darker side of show business which has
changed more recently but like
stories like that would be like
malicious gossip
it wouldn't be like the victims
themselves were speaking it would more
be the things that like the kind of
stuff that's in kenneth is hollywood
babylon it feels like sort of like
sort of malicious gossip about sort of
stories like that
so i i uh i had this research and and as
i was kind of thinking about doing it
and i kept going off and doing other
movies then i met christy um through sam
mendes and i would now like to give the
floor and let you tell the rest of the
story
um yeah sam introduced us because he
and i quote said oh you guys will get on
like a house on fire which um was true
uh and we met we met for the first time
on the night that the brexit vote had
been passed through so we were drowning
our sorrows and we were in soho during
our sorrows and we just happened to be
drinking across from the strip club that
i used to live above
and i mentioned oh i used to live above
there it was really noisy and also i
worked in a bar around the corner and he
was like oh i have this idea that's set
in soho but set and kind of like you
know not the glossy part of soho the
seedier part and i was like oh i know
that world
absolutely and so we went on we went on
a night out to like a lot of the sort of
dingy bars and we ended up in the
basement bar tricia's
uh on greek street and edgar told me the
entire story there like over drinks and
i remember kind of sitting just gripping
the table listening and just being tired
to be on this ride um and i like
instantly fell in love with it i mean
just the whole story totally had me uh
and then it was about nine months later
i got a lovely phone call from edgar
saying hey do you remember that story i
was like yeah i kind of think about it
every time i walk through soho which is
about five times a week um and then he
was like do you want to write it with me
and i was like yes i do yes i do and
then you flew back to london
and he had a writing office in soho and
i remember at cycling and i had the
playlist already because that was sent
to me as part of the you know i had a
playlist cycling into work listen to the
playlist arrived and i i mean it's fair
to say your office did look a bit
like you were hunting a serial killer it
was like all these cards up in the wall
and i found out later you were worried
that i was going to bolt
but actually that's my aesthetic because
i'm a writer so my house looks like i'm
either a serial killer or trying to
catch serial killer
started to work on it um
i know i mean like you know i think six
weeks we had the first draft
wow
that's awesome
that's incredible and so were you
writing in the same room this is always
my big question you know so you wrote in
the same room yeah
at one point the people in the office
next to us came and i think it was at
the point where i'd played sandy shore's
puppet on a string three times in a row
will you please turn it down
[Laughter]
brooklyn with sandy shore at one point
by the way totally love that she is
named sandy with an ie i caught it
immediately and then when puppet on a
string comes on i was like oh please
i got this you'll appreciate this story
at one point like whilst having a
meeting about the movie a working title
who who's like produced the movie
they have these conference rooms with
like glass walls so i was like talking
about the movie i can't remember what we
were talking about whether it's like
financing or casting or something but i
was distracted by somebody walking
through the office
and that i was like and i just stopped
and stopped what i was saying then i
said was that sandy shore
and eric found in the produce said oh
yeah she's having a meeting with tim i
said
sandy shaw's in the office i guess like
it was so strange because we were like
talking about this movie and then she
kind of walked through like an angel
very oh my god oh my god as a good omen
so good i love that i didn't see whether
she was wearing shoes on them i was
gonna ask i was gonna
be
um so you talked about the playlist
christy and and i'm fascinated by the
playlist as well because i can't write
it's almost sometimes the song happens
before the character for me
so i can't write without the playlist
and um by the way loving the playlist on
spotify and can't wait for the double
vinyl lp
so um
how do you
explain how that works for people who
are
just beginning writers or just
or don't even know
how that works
well i think in a weird way with this
film and it's been similar with some of
my previous films like baby driver with
this film it's like i know i know what
the story is and i know the kind of song
that i want to be in it and i so i
started to zero in on specific songs and
particularly the female singers of the
day sandy shore patriot clark dusty
springfield cilla black
because
like those like songs of that time that
even the sort of
like obviously the balors but even the
more upbeat ones they all kind of like
sort of so like stained with tears
there's this melancholic bittersweet
kind of edge to them
that this felt like this is really
within the tone of the movie so that was
a big part of it and then it was other
sort of like songs that kind of just
like so just
like felt that they kind of had like a
kind of a
almost like a sort of ghostly evocative
edge like i think like
peter and gordon's world without love
that opens the movie if it's an upbeat
song but it feels like a sad song it was
like a sort of ghostly song to me so
it'd be a lot of those songs that were
kind of kind of like hit me kind of in
the sort of like
the sort of the heart that there was
something kind of like sort of very sad
about them and so but in a way as i was
kind of coming up with the story long
before christy came on board i would
sort of maybe similar to you alison the
songs that almost become like post-it
notes like you must make this movie
don't forget to make this movie and then
if those songs would come up either like
i hear them out in the world or they
just come up on shuffle i'd be like oh
my god you know i'd hear our dean
taylor's goes to my house saying i have
to make last night in soho you know
um can i can i mention how you come into
it allison
please
[Laughter]
so this is a story this is this is why
having allison moderate the skewed a is
just like the the the closing of the
circle so maybe as far back as like 2008
i was with credit tarantino at his house
and he just brought out death proof
which had
whole type by dave d dozie bikini mick
and titch in the film and we were
talking about that song and i said that
i really love that song he said have you
ever heard last night in soho
and i said no and he played it for me
and he said this is um this is the best
like end music for a film that doesn't
exist
and that kind of stuck in my head and i
like the song and because i in writing i
had started to amass this playlist of
60s music british 60s music from a
particular period that was maybe like
300 songs long and then i got it down to
like sort of like
70 which with the players would be
called soho five stars
so these were like sort of the kind of
the ones that would start to form the
soundtrack and within that group was now
last night in soho by dave d dodkin
mkhitch then like i called the film a
number of other titles first i had the
working type was like red light or red
light area
and then um and then i changed it to the
knight has a thousand eyes named after
the bobby v song until i found out that
there was already a film called the
night has a thousand eyes and then
eventually it was staring me in the face
last night in soho that's the title of
the movie
so then i changed the title and i didn't
i hadn't spoken to quentin for a while
because he was making once per time in
hollywood and it was announced in the
trades and the next time i spoke to him
i said i said hey
did you see the title of my new movie
and he says yeah last night in soho and
i said you're not mad at me that i like
chose that tile he goes you know what i
just thought if anybody could make a
movie with last night in soho it's edgar
and i said well i'm gonna thank you at
the end of the movie goes hey well if
you thank me you have to thank alice
hernandez because she's the one who said
who originally came up with the thing of
last night in sega is the best end
titles
entitled music for a movie that doesn't
exist so if you thank me you have to
thank allison i'm like dumb so then if
we saw on the thanks at the end it says
and what's funny is that you're just
alphabetically you're both sides of the
thanks list it starts with you and it
ends it's quentin
so much and then i emailed allison maybe
like a couple of months ago to tell her
that she was thanked at the end of the
movie and explain why
and then you said what's your address
and then you sent to me in london a
seven-inch single of last night in soho
by dave the doughty bikini mixtape i
want to say on record in front of
everybody thank you alice
[Laughter]
oh man
now i'm going to tell you something i
haven't told you before which was when i
saw that you were making a movie called
last night in soho
my heart sank because i went
oh that's wonderful and then i thought
but he'll never know that i gave quentin
that song
and you know he'll never i and i'm never
gonna tell him that
and then you sent this to me
and i couldn't believe it it was just
the most amazing thing you know that i
got that it came
so beautifully full circle and these
guys were down for me man
[Laughter]
just incredible and i'll tell you that
when when that
when i heard that those first notes of
that
fucking amazing song come up over those
end credits i just bawled i just wept i
went five times but especially on that
one
you know it's funny quentin saw it the
other day in london and he like said it
made him cry like three times and i said
what bits made you cry and he said he
said when the silla black song started
playing maybe yeah when she walks out
he said he was double he said he started
sniffling when silly black life started
singing and then he really started
bawling when he saw silla black
and then he said the next thing is he he
he the the end without going too much
into stuff just is like
you know in the end with kind of the
revelation you know at the end like i'm
really like sort of limit and then and
then the final thing is he said and then
hearing dave d does he make a touch like
on the end credits made him cry
unbelievable you're the same so you guys
are twins we really are we really are
and we had a whole d
dozy beaky mick and titch exchange of
records for
like about five or six years and um
and uh yeah it just i'll tell you
another another point for me was just
yeah there was there's uh well no i
can't um but there was a beauty um
i had five different times that i that i
uh that i just was totally teared up
so um and i think that you know it's
this idea too that there's um
these two women looking out for each
other there's something about this sense
of um
of uh you know
one thing that i've never seen
really in a movie before
is when ellie's in the cab and she's
feeling like okay i'm having a friendly
conversation and then with the cabbie
and then she gets
uneasy and then she gets scared
and that sense of trepidation um
for a young woman or for an old woman by
the way
you know um
is uh
you had to walk such a fine balance of
like not saying girls stay at home
but girls beware and and and showing
what that experience is is like for
women of never quite knowing intentions
male intentions and i thought that was
spectacular and that by doing the two
different time periods
these women could have different
experiences of that
how did you walk that line
well i think you know i think exactly
what you said is exactly it it's like in
the previous scene
you know like peggy played by rita
tashing has warned her like moms or
grandmothers do
but then the cabbie scene you know i
mean
it's definitely creepy but that it's
that thing like sort of like you don't
know and like and it's deliberately left
ambiguous and we don't need to kind of
is whether the cabbie is genuinely i
mean he's obviously like malevolent but
like that cab driver if he was kind of
like drawn on it would say oh no i'm
just joking i'm just joking haven't you
got a sense of humor that kind of
bullshit response or can you compliment
can't you take a compliment
darling right
yes
yes smart more you know just like that
you know like uh yeah i mean
i mean you can christy i mean
those lines you've heard out loud yeah
yeah
you know the the sleazy pickup line in
the bar you know we were sitting right
in one day edgar's like what's the worst
pickup line you've ever heard in the bar
and i was like i got it right to hand
and it was like oh my dick just died can
i bury it in your arse like that kind of
thing or and the taxi driver as well i
mean i wouldn't say that was just one
taxi driver and i don't want to tar the
london taxi drivers because i still like
to get left places but like over the
years like definitely had stuff that had
been said to me i'd never i never put
anything in the script there and those
scenes that hadn't been said to me or
one of my friends and i think it's like
it is one of those things like as a
young woman moving through the city
especially city like london which has
this kind of like you know undercurrent
and just as fastness that you do feel
uneasy and i think you know really good
horror stories should play on things
that are actually frightening and that
stuff is actually frightening to me yes
like viewing that into the script so
that you know and that is frightening to
men and women it's not just women that
aren't prey but i think most women would
get it absolutely absolutely and it's
and it underlies a lot of stuff and how
we look out for our daughters and how we
look out for our granddaughters or our
sisters or our best friends
and um you don't want to tell them don't
live your life don't thrive don't you
just want to go but
watch out be aware
plan for it yes be empowered but be
aware exactly
and um
oh go ahead i know this is interesting i
was just reading rita tashing and did an
interview in the guardian today about
promoting the movie and she watched it a
couple of weeks ago and obviously she's
not in like the the contemporary london
scenes she's not in the 60s scenes but
she was asked about like what she
thought about the
the scenes in the 60s and she said she
goes oh no i mean there was a lot of
that going on there was a lot of young
actresses being exploited and we used to
have a code word dom dirty old man a
watch out and he's a dom
so it was interesting and she sort of
said yeah you know you just had to keep
your wits about you and kind of figure
out who was like who was trouble but it
was very difficult because they were
everywhere and i think that's one thing
i was going to say about the 60 scenes
as well that we sort of like in terms of
threading the needle the other equally
disturbing part to it to me at least his
same matt's miss character
is the and he deserves no sympathy but i
think there's an element where matt
smith's character thinks that he's doing
the right thing or rather not doing the
right thing but this is the way that it
works that terrible phrase of like this
is the way that it works so he like has
that phrase which is kind of like a
horrible
gaslighting phrase which has
unfortunately been said to too many
people and not just in the 60s but the
thing of like um everybody else is doing
it what makes you so special so using
the kind of the sense that like you're
gonna lose out
unless you do this thing is such a sort
of a dangerous weapon to use against
everybody like mind games and coercion
but i think unfortunately that's a lot
of what i want to say i don't even use
it in the past sense of saying that's
what happened in the business we know
too much that that continued way past
the 60s but
writing those kind of lines was was
writing sort of like
plausible lines but also something that
even matt smith's character in his head
you you know that that character would
never refer to himself as a pimp you
know that he would have fooled himself
into thinking i am the manager manager
exactly the way that it works you know
so that stuff was like we you know
we drew on some like sort of
very dark stuff um both not just from
like um
you know the research that had been done
but also just in terms of
you know i guess playing on sort of on
the contemporary problems as well so
yeah
yeah it really uh it
it really comes off
this way as well because ellie's having
to dodge
not the same stuff
as sandy but she's having to dodge her
own
experiences of that of exploitation
um
well we're getting toward the end but i
have to mention that we're all three we
all three went to london as young people
and there is i mean i was closer to this
to the 60s than you guys were i was
there in 73
um
but uh but it was fascinating to think
back i mean i lived in a counter you
know with bunch of counter culture
english dudes you know but
but i still i remember coming home one
day and saying um
they were like what'd you do today i was
like oh yeah i went to the tate and i
went to a pub and they were like a pub
by yourself
and like that wasn't done and then i was
like oh i guess that's why everybody was
looking at me weird i thought it was
just because i was an american hippie
girl you know
but um but it's strange that um because
you know in america you could certainly
walk into bars as a woman by yourself
but
um but it's strange how different
the um
like there was a dark side and there was
a repression that people don't think
about in terms of the 60s and the 70s
god knows because you think oh it was
the ideal time and in london at the time
and it was this
it was this uh you know time of freedom
so how did you exp that was my dark side
of london
not to mention my relationship at the
time but uh
but um how did you experience uh that
side of london
as young people
well
i mean i think sort of like in terms of
i mean my experience of coming to london
was you know we used the phrase country
mouse in the movie because i come from
somerset and coming to london as a 20
year old you know it's such a sort of
forbidding experience just in terms of
um oh how am i going to fit in i'm not
rich enough i'm not cool enough i don't
know anybody how can i possibly make a
foothold in this
you know london can be a very cold and
hard city like initially and some people
never crack it
i think um
i think the other thing is just to touch
on what you said was interesting was um
you know i i think uh
what was interesting as well is that
you know
diana rigg at one point tommy you know
said the story when
when we were like sort of on the set i
happened she's not in the cafe to paris
scene but like i happen to mention that
we the cafe de paris was a set that
marcus rowans did that's a recreation of
the 60s version it's like an incredible
set and i said i said oh we you know we
got the cafe de paris there and diana
riggs said oh i went to the cafe to
perry on my 18th birthday
and i sir saw shirley bassey's first
london gig
i was like
wow okay and i said well do you want to
do you want to see the set before you go
home
so i had this very magical experience of
walking diana rigg through an empty
sound stage onto the cafeteria and she
at first said um
oh my god this is amazing oh it looks
exactly like was tell your production
designer he did an amazing job
and then there was that dot dot dot
where they sort of like you know that
like another part of the story is coming
and she said
i remember walking down those stairs and
lots of roomy-eyed men looking me up and
down and feeling like a piece of meat
and
yeah we got in the car and kind of went
back home and i just thought like she
just like summed up the entire movie
like sort of it was very sort of and i
didn't think she was even thinking about
it in in connection to the script but it
was very sort of profound to me to just
hear her say that um
so it's and it also just i guess the
other thing is why i brought this up
because i want you know chrissy has you
know her own experiences coming to
london the other thing is interesting to
me in terms of one of the things that
inspired me was that there were a lot of
those movies in the 60s about girls
coming to london
and
most of them written and directed by men
and a lot of them in a very moralistic
way
seeming to like slap the wrist of the
younger generation so it kind of felt
that they were quite punitive movies
that like girl comes to london and wants
to be a star and gets roundly like
punished for her efforts
and i thought that was like i saw a lot
of those movies and i thought that was
fascinating and i think
like you said it's like the sort of the
the perception of the 60s is that they
were permissive and progressive but the
reality was is that lots of
old men took advantage of that
exactly
sorry i was i went on a big tangent i
was going
i love anytime i get to hear a story
about dana egg i'm i'm perfectly content
please um i mean for me you know i was
22 when i moved to london and i
much like early like i hadn't come from
the country i come from glasgow which is
kind of a different world
and then moving to london you know with
the hopes of being a screenwriter and
that worked out and i'm really pleased
about it but you know there was like no
guarantee and i worked in a bar and i
lived above a strip club and and i like
you know
used to kind of
my door to get into my flat was like on
the strip club like under the sign
and there was two bouncers that used to
like turn men away because people would
try and follow me up the stairs i would
like have to like make sure the door was
shut behind me like it was you know if
you if you're out in about soho one
o'clock in the morning and you're a
woman on your own you're noticed
uh and then the other thing about it was
the bar that i worked in was great and i
and i was very protected there and i was
looked after and they were in my london
family i actually took the owners to the
premier in london it was great and
they've got tremendous stories because
the the owner carol she used to date one
of the rolling stones in the 60s so she
was like such a wealth of knowledge to
like that era but there was also like
some of the customers that would
frequent the bar had been there since
the 60s and and had lived through kind
of like these times
and had worked in all different areas
and then of course there were still sex
workers in london in soho when i was
there which you know would be a few
years ago now but it still existed and
there used to be a dominatrix that
worked across
from the bar
and she would come in after every shift
and tell us about her clients and so it
was like really as a 22 year old fairly
tame
like scottish person it was quite like
an eye-opening experience to be thrust
into this world and to walk by you know
alleyways and to walk by like you know
you know these clothes that go up into
houses that have models written on them
and stuff like that so yeah that my
experience was like right next to the
glossy kind of like showbiz editing
suites and and like you know seeing
famous people on the streets you would
also see prostitutes you would also see
this like undercover world and i think
when edgar first told me about that
story i thought oh that's the perfect
because soho is a character in itself in
the story and it needs to breathe it
needs to be allowed to be seen to be the
very didactic thing that it is and so
that that was the very first thing that
hooked me as someone who loved soho and
also hated it
yes
well that's that's really a kind of
feeling you get in the movie
with ellie because it represents her
sense of pursuing her dream
and her mother's
um as well but uh but also this this uh
this sense of like like not wanting to
be there at the same time really really
not wanting to be there
um
but uh but knowing that that it's got
that that place is gonna hold something
for her
and i love that it goes into her work as
well i mean don't we love that where our
hauntings go into the work that we make
um
my god you guys i love this movie so
much that i could talk forever and thank
you for like
showing color in a film again i thought
i'd never color return
i just was like oh my god i can see
everything that the actors are doing
it's lit
and it's got lots of color yay
no more green scenes
i was just my my tribute to kind of 60s
eastman color and technicolor yeah it
works dude it works
thank you i love the movie i can't wait
to see it again and probably again and
again and i'm going to get to
that vinyl that double vinyl will be out
soon i'll get you one you get a free one
allison come on
i mean let me just say this it's a good
job that you like the movie because but
because because you have a thanks credit
it'll be on your imdb forever so thank
god you like it
oh yeah
bragging rights
oh lovely lovely time you guys
thank you so much thank you can't wait
to meet you christy yeah see you soon
good luck with this fabulous movie
that was great
[Music]